kikaru thank you so much for joining me
today in recent years you've become the
most popular chess streamer you've built
up an amazing audience you want the
speed Chess Championship so many times
you're the and you recently climbed up
to world number three
uh what stands behind your success
um I mean I think obviously a lot has
changed in the last couple of years I
think certainly I've found something
that I enjoy a lot I think when you have
a lot of positivity in your life and
you're very passionate about the various
projects that I'm working on I think it
certainly translates across the board I
think as far as chess goes there isn't a
whole lot that changes I think mostly
it's about opening preparation the
amount of time you study and I think I
found a very good balance between being
practical in terms of approaching games
a certain way and then also studying
when I need to but just finding a
finding the right balance I think is
more important than sort of going over
the edge and spending too much time
studying or spending your entire life
really just just worrying about what
other top players are doing and it seems
to be working out
and did you do something in particular
to prepare for this event
[Music]
um no for this event I didn't do
anything to repair I think uh with uh
99lx 960 Fisher random chest certainly
uh for the most part it's about the
creativity at the board coming with that
coming up with ideas right before it
begins just starting with other players
and so I don't think it's that important
I think perhaps there's certain setups
that even from having played in the past
I have some idea of where pieces belong
but for the most part it's Unique it's
different and I also think one big
difference is on move number one for the
most part you can play any move and I
know when I played here last year there
there were a lot of people studying some
of us were studying with other players
some of us were on our own like myself
and olly Reza and um and I think most
games I try to do something different
than what everyone else is doing and
even then I think I got decent positions
so the fact that you can play unique
openings from start makes it quite
different than uh just classical normal
chess and for that reason I really do
enjoy it and you have 15 minutes to
prepare for your next game do you how
important are those 15 minutes for you
to kind of get ready you mentioned you
might be doing it on your own maybe
you'll partner with someone this year
but yeah I mean I I think um for the
most part it's not super important I
think just having the first couple of
moves is all that really matters you
know some events are like here where you
are on your own no computer assistance
some events you're allowed to use
computer assistance I think in both
cases though the game is unique pretty
much as early as move number five um no
matter what I remember when I played a
match against Magnus some years back
where we were allowed to actually get
the position and and look at it with
computers and I remember even in that
match somewhere around move two or move
three already it was not what I looked
at or Max looked at and so I think in
both cases it's going to be unique from
the start so it's more about just having
some general idea but mostly it's about
figuring it out once the game has begun
and what do you think is an important
type of exercise that people should do
or maybe that you do in order to improve
your visualization skills ah so this is
just about in general I think um you
know the biggest thing is doing uh doing
puzzles a lot of stuff has become very
commercialized over the last couple of
years in particular and I think you know
some people look at like things like
puzzle rush for example as being
beneficial I actually would argue that
just doing puzzles without any of the
gimmicky stuff like timers or anything
else but just looking and trying to
puzzle slash tactics is arguably the
most important thing anyone can do
um because it's the one thing where
there is no pressure on you you can take
your time and figure it out whereas if
you are playing say games of Chess which
is another way of trying to improve as
quickly as possible you can play you can
play games where you have to go back
with the games try and understand and
also in the Split Second moments when
you're making decisions you aren't
always going to make the best decisions
it's not always replicable and so I
think mainly just doing doing puzzles
nowadays of course everyone does it
online
um whether it's online whether from a
book but basically uh just um just just
doing puzzles slash tactics as much as
you can any blindfold chance at all
uh I mean blindfold trust I think
anybody below a certain level cannot do
it I think blindfold is is very good if
you're maybe expert level player 2000
but if you're below that I think it's
borderline impossible and I think
there's no no actual benefit from it and
I I know from personal experience um
that a lot of people who I who I know
who are in like the 1600 1700 rating
range they simply can't visualize they
can't do the sequences even when they
see the board in their head so I think
it's just not really productive at all
and of course you're known that you've
become a really strong player at the
beginning by playing a lot of bullet
chess
um what do you enjoy the most chest wise
do you enjoy blades uh Rapids classical
chess if you were to just pick one where
would be or someone yeah I mean I think
for me Blitz is my favorite Blitz or
what I would classify as like Fast
rabbits like 15 minutes with 10 second
increments something like this um slow
rapid I don't particularly like with 25
minutes I find it to be a little bit too
slow not fast I'm somewhere in between
classical and Blitz
um so probably like the fast rap with 15
minutes or or just Blitz like three
three plus one or three plus two with
the with the slight increment final
question for you Hikaru whom are you
looking for the most to play in this
competition of course of course you've
played probably everyone so many times
but is there a particular player you're
excited to play yeah I think I mean for
me playing against Gary is always a
great pleasure he's from a different
generation I think when when I look at
like myself Fabiano Lavon or others I
think we're oftentimes asked maybe not
so much in recent years but in the past
at least one of the most common
questions if you could go back in time
and play someone from another generation
who are you playing I would say pretty
Universal at least I think myself
Fabiano and Lavon all pretty much answer
the same way which is we would love to
have played Bobby Fisher and so I think
considering the general Generations that
we're from you know you always want to
play people who came before you they're
the people the idols that we all looked
up to as we were growing up and so
playing Gary is always very special even
if he's not as strong as he once was
he's still still one of the greatest
players of all time and having that
opportunity I think is very special and
since you mentioned Fisher if you don't
don't mind me asking one one last thing
he was he often said how important the
ability of special perception is in
chess do you feel that
um what do you think is the most
important in chess 960 is it pattern
recognition visualization is it the pawn
structure is there something specific
that I think one of the great things
about fisherandom is that the players
have to figure it out at the board and I
I would say it's not too different
actually if you look at just regular
chess going back say 150 or 200 years
now uh these days when we look you look
at Players like Paul morphy or some of
the early grades in chess we tend to
think they were very good at the time
but they you know they don't hold up
against modern players but I think
certainly it's the exact same skill set
where back then you had to figure it out
now you have to do the same thing and
you know one of the things is that as
Graves we are at regular chess there
still are a lot of blunders that that
occur when you look at it with the
computers when we're playing each other
and so for that reason I think there's a
lot of room to explore and I think
generally the players were more creative
native I would say the players who rely
a little bit less on Preparation tend to
do better 960 I would very specifically
refer to players like magnus's great
intuition myself and probably Wesley so
as well I think we're we're players who
of course we can do preparation and
we're very strong players but I think
our general feel is is a little bit
better in terms of the intuition and
unique way of looking at looking at
chess and I think that helps us a lot in
Fisher random thank you so much hikara I
wish you good luck and looking forward
to seeing you play this tournament thank
you
foreign
[Music]